écrit à quelle merveilleuse initiative
d'avoir proposé à crystal de passer le
week-end avec nous un peu alex lutz a
trois passions dans la vie les chevaux
si l'humour
et la télé des années 60 à 90 p 1 venez
dans mon monde après stéréo top et guy
au cinéma il est de retour dans une
nouvelle création originale
délicieusement vintage
inspiré d'un sauf des années 80 la
vengeance au triple galop revisite avec
brio les codes du genre pour moi c'est
vraiment une parodie hommage est pas une
parodie moqueuse
bon j'adore c'est surtout le côté
parodie c'est à dire de prendre le code
et d'automne je me sers un scotch de la
ville de scotch en floride on avait
souvent des personnages qui se parlent
sans se regarder ça c'est des trucs
qu'ils faisaient dans les séries mais
quelle complètement absurde ménagez vous
on est très sensible à l'étalonnage des
images au mix du son travail de son et
d'image mélanger c'était des voix de
doublage qui faisait dans ces séries là
donc ça sonne un peu bizarre où la
bohème avec son
fils
dans le rôle de l'héroïne audrey lamy
interprète une jeune héritière quelque
peu naïve que cela vous plaise ou non
nous sommes un couple d'amoureux transis
la grande naïve mais attention
la roue tourne
j'ai moi même une revanche à prendre sur
la vie
le casting cinq étoiles dans le rouge ou
décoiffante il ya deux choses que je
sais reconnaître dans la vie les fausses
crème de jour et les vrais crimes de
sang alors comment j'ai réussi à
convaincre ces gens là juste pas en leur
disant bien déjouer avec nous dans notre
truc appelé mobile
servane on l'a tout ça je pense qu'on
préférait il préfère cette clameur
là pour le coup on est vraiment des
enfants qui vont à toutes les références
avec lesquels on a grandi en fait
[Musique]
c'est un personnage qu'on a extirpé du
groupe modern talking
on a gravé en faire des tonnes on en a
même de voir
à jouer c'est un kiff du mental tu joues
en douze jours ce qu'une actrice rêve de
jouer en une carrière si ça peut
vraiment elle passe d'un truc d'un
opposé à l'autre en très peu de temps
signés ces documents
dire que nous n'avons pas de stylo comme
son nom amour c'est une histoire de
vengeance et comme dans toutes ses sagas
tout est dit mais tu regardes quand même
et nous avons besoin d'un stylo nous
n'en avons pas
[Musique]